[Music]
one of the strangest yet most intriguing
aspects of friedrich nietzsche's ideas
is his repeated enthusiasm for a concept
that he called amor
farty translated from the latin as a
love of one's fate or as we might put it
a resolute enthusiastic acceptance of
everything that has happened in one's
life the person of amor fati doesn't
seek to erase anything of their past but
rather accepts what has occurred the
good and the bad the mistaken and the
wise with strength and an all-embracing
gratitude that borders on a kind of
enthusiastic affection this refusal to
regret and retouch the past is heralded
as a virtue at many points in
Nietzsche's work in his book the gay
science written during a period of great
personal hardship for the philosopher
Nietzsche writes I want to learn more
and more to see as beautiful what is
necessary in things then I shall be one
of those who makes things beautiful amor
fati let that be my love henceforth I
don't want to wage war against what is
ugly I don't want to accuse I don't even
want to accuse those who accuse looking
away shall be my only negation and all
in all and on the whole someday I wish
to be only a yes Sayer and a few years
later in ecco homo Nietzsche writes my
formula for greatness in a human being
is amor fati that one wants nothing to
be different not forward not backwards
not in all eternity not merely bare what
is necessary
still less conceal it but love it in
most areas of life most of the time we
do the very opposite we spend a huge
amount of time taking stock of our
errors regretting and lamenting the
unfortunate twists of fate and wishing
that things could have gone differently
we are typically mighty opponents of
anything that smacks of resignation or
fatalism we want to alter any
move things ourselves politics the
economy the course of history
and part of this means refusing to be
passive about the errors in justices and
ugliness of our own and the collective
past Nietzsche himself in some moods
knows this defiance full well there is
much emphasis in his work on action
initiative and self assertion his
concept of the village saw marked or
will to power embodies just this
attitude of vitality and conquest of
obstacles however he's aware that in
order to lead a good life we need to
keep in mind plenty of opposing ideas
and marshal them as and when they become
relevant we don't in Nietzsche's eyes
need to be consistent we need to have
the ideas to hand that can solve our
wounds Nietzsche isn't therefore asking
us to choose between glorious fatalism
on the one hand or a vigorous willing on
the other he is allowing us to have
recourse to either intellectual move
depending on the occasion he wishes are
mental toolkit to have more than one set
of ideas to have as it were both hammer
and a saw certain occasions particularly
need the wisdom of a will driven
philosophy others demand that we know
how to accept embrace and stop fighting
the inevitable in Nietzsche's own life
there was much that he had tried to
change and overcome he had fled his
restrictive family in Germany and
escaped to the Swiss Alps he had tried
to get away from the narrowness of
academia and become a freelance writer
he had tried to find a wife who could be
both a lover and an intellectual
soulmate but a lot in this project of
self creation and self overcoming had
gone terribly wrong he couldn't get his
parents especially his mother and sister
out of his head Nietzsche's books sold
dismally and he was forced more or less
to beg from friends and family in order
to keep going meanwhile his halting
gauche attempts to seduce women were met
by ridicule and rejection there must
have been so many lamentations and
regrets running through his mind
his walks across the upper anger Dean
and his knights in his modest wooden
chalet in SILS Maria
if only I'd stuck with an academic
career if only I'd been more confident
around certain women if only I'd written
in a more populist style if only I'd
been born in France it was because such
thoughts and every one of us has our own
distinct variety of them can ultimately
be so destructive and so soul sapping
that the idea of amor fati grew
compelling to Nietzsche amor fati was
the idea that he needed in order to
regain sanity after hours of
self-recrimination and criticism it's
the idea we ourselves may need at 4:00
a.m.
finally to quieten a mind that has
started Naurang into itself shortly
after midnight it's an idea with which a
troubled spirit can greet the first
signs of dawn at the height of the mood
of amor fati we recognized that things
really could not have been otherwise
because everything we are and have done
is bound closely together in a web of
consequences that began with our birth
in which we are powerless to alter at
will we see that what went right and
what went horribly wrong are as one and
we commit ourselves to accepting both to
no longer destructively hoping that
things could have been otherwise we were
headed to a degree of catastrophe from
the start we end up saying with tears in
which their mingled grief and a sort of
ecstasy a large yes to the whole of life
in its absolute horror and occasional
moments of Awesome beauty in a letter to
a friend written in the summer of 1882
Nietzsche try to sum up the new spirit
of acceptance that he had learnt to lean
on to protect him from the agony of
regret I am in a mood of fatalistic
surrender to God I call it a more fatty
so much so that I would be willing to
rush into a lion's jaws and that is
where after a bit too much regret we
should learn sometimes to join him thank
you for watching if you want to learn
more about the thinkers from our videos
check out our great thinkers book
available worldwide and now as an e-book
you